one of the reasons why we Coupee dia is
so messed up is that there is no
formalized way of arriving at a decision
about disputed questions so you go there
you've got a question about you know
what what should the the definition of
racism be extremely hot topic it should
be possible for people to come up with a
bunch of different options and maybe
have a round-robin competition or
something like that and and actually get
a legitimate choice that's not what they
do they pretend that it is possible to
have a consensus about these things and
that the consensus is determined
basically by the people in power on the
topic you know River whoever has the
most seniority or seems to have the most
allies or whatever those are the people
who basically declare the consensus so
it's not a consensus it's just putting a
cynical description on what is not it
consensus all the decision-making
process needs to be reduced to very
specific editorial decisions to be made
and then taking legitimate votes based
on that
I'm joined by Larry Sanger who is the X
founder of Wikipedia among many other
things
Larry welcome to the show well thanks
for having me on I appreciate it really
good to have you here
first things first I've never heard the
term X founder before what if you
explained usually what that means please
yeah I made it up yesterday okay a
couple of days ago yeah I I did a face a
Twitter poll about it and and over fifty
percent of the people thought it was a
good title for me to claim so I was once
considered by everyone co-founder even
Jimmy Wales but then then he started
denying me the founder the title like in
2005 which everyone thought was
ridiculous but he was insisting on it so
it's a little bit of a dig at him for
that but it's also whenever I tell
people online that I'm co-founder of
Wikipedia especially in the last I don't
know three or six months they've started
getting costal toward me personally it's
like you know Wikipedia is out of
control they say no and you know you're
you must be the double if you actually
started it and and so I'm I'm distancing
myself from it because I have been a
critic of Wikipedia for well I'm one of
the first critics of Wikipedia frankly
outside of the very original naysayers
but you know yeah and and then and then
I've been gone for a long time so
sometimes when when I tell people I'm
co-founder and and but now I'm working
on whatever my latest project is
they get confused and they think oh so
you they seem to assume that I just left
it like a couple years ago no I live in
2002 I prominently distanced myself from
the project in 2003 and I've been
working on all kinds of other things
since then so okay but I got it started
yeah and also world's first X found it
which is I think so that's right I think
I founded I founded the term yeah you
are the ex found a founder so before we
get into Wikipedia and where it's at at
the moment and also your exit could you
could you tell us the genesis story
could you tell us how it how it started
on your side okay well I first met Jimmy
Wales in the mid 1990s through our comm
interest in in philosophy actually it
was mine Rand I joined one of his
mailing lists and later on made one
myself and he joined that about
philosophy and we lost touch for a few
years but then I was sharing a idea that
I had for what would later become a blog
around early 2000 and one of the people
that I shared the idea with was Jimmy
Wales and he wrote back and he said
don't work on that work on this thing
you'd be you know editor-in-chief of an
encyclopedia and I was like wow this
sounds great I like those practically my
dream job it's something if I wasn't
gonna be a professor of philosophy which
by that time I decided not to be even
though it's I was all but dissertation
at the time it would be you know like an
editor of an encyclopedia that's sounded
great
so it was my job to to start nupedia and
you pedia and that was to be built
the principles of open source software
so there was this guy wrote an essay
called called the cathedral and the
bazaar his name is Eric Raymond I was
told to read this it's still a great
thing to read and it explains how
volunteers can get together to build
great things online simply by sharing a
common vision and common needs solving
common problems but in a way that
results in something that that lives in
the Commons and so that's that that was
the idea and the problem was we wanted
nupedia to be as trustworthy as possible
so we had this 7 step really arduous
editorial process and not many people
wanted to go through it so we generated
only a few dozen articles in the first
year and that wasn't good enough so so
we were will agreed that there needed to
be a new source of content for the
project and so I made some different
proposals and Jimmy Wales he he you know
dismissed them all because they it would
involve more coding and then a friend of
mine January 2nd 2001 told me about this
software called wiki software are very
Boober geeky where you go to a web page
and you click an edit button and you can
you can edit the text of the page right
there on the page and hit save and your
changes are instantly live and it was an
insane sounding idea but you know ok
even by that time I had been living
online for you know the better part of
10 years and and so it wasn't that hard
to imagine how it actually might work
so he got me excited enough about the
idea that I'd I started thinking well
this could solve the problem that we
were having with nupedia and so I ran
home actually and made a one-page
proposal to Jimmy Wales basically saying
set up the software for me to you know
work on a new project you know and
originally it was going to be the
nupedia wiki but then the editors of of
nupedia are they there were mostly PhD
academics they didn't want to have
anything to do with anything called a
wiki it just did not have this sort of
credibility and and after that they
wanted to be associated with and they
were really good people actually there
are some famous scholars even among them
and well so we decided fine we still
want to do this it just won't be
associated with the new PDF with the
name Wikipedia and we launched it and
internally on January 10th I guess it
was I had already populated it with help
pages and things like that and we added
some more some first articles and then
we we launched it to the broader world
and the the the nupedia community
included on January 15th and and because
there were already like 2,000 people on
the nupedia mailing list which I had
collected in the previous year I and and
in an assistant that we had collecting
people we do we actually we're really
able to start you know hit the ground
running basically and yeah it just I
mean it grew faster than anyone expected
it to and it was sort of my job in the
beginning
to teach the very idea of an
encyclopedia article to people who
wanted to use because it was just
basically an online blank bulletin board
that anyone could write anything to so
you could dictionary definitions you
could write personal essays you could do
whatever and and just gradually I pushed
people toward you know writing an
encyclopedia article begins with
something like a definition or a general
description of the term you know and and
and systematically lays out the the
basic facts and explained basic policies
like neutrality so I was a big advocate
of that and I'm the the main author of
the original version of nupedia and
Wikipedia's neutrality policies and
various other policies too so it has
changed a bit since the first year since
like the end of the first year but not
that much actually
so it's interesting the biggest thing
that has changed since then is that it
was sort of taken over by people that
back then I would have considered be
trolls and or at least people who did
not always have the interests of
neutrality and a serious approach to the
subjects at heart often had access to
grind and also were just difficult to
get along with unless you pay laid their
game so that's when that all that
started toward the end the very first
year or the logic even not soon yeah oh
yeah yeah and that's actually why I
ended up distancing myself so after like
I worked on it for the first fourteen
months got it
really going Jimmy wills actually
basically he's given me credit for
coming up with the idea and later denied
the same thing and that I was like
essential to the project but then it
turns out that I wasn't essential to the
project I mean it was set up that's the
nature of a wiki it was set up so that
it could be to a certain extent
self-managing it's pretty robust
you know and but I I permanently
distanced myself from the wiki community
like a year after laid off because they
couldn't afford to pay me basically the
the bottom fell out of the the dot-com
boom of the late 90s and early 2000s and
yeah so they lost their contracts and
were not able to pay any of the new
people anyway yeah and a year after that
I basically said this this project is
you know becoming dominated by people
that I would have considered bad actors
before and you're you are absolutely
driving away some of the very best
people that we recruited for nupedia and
if this is the case then it's gonna end
up being a real problem you know and I
think I I was right so I gave I gave
Jimmy Wales an ultimatum so you do
something about these problems or I'm
going to distance myself from the
project permanently and he simply denied
that there were any of the problems that
I listed and so I said okay bye-bye and
I I've been kind of a critic ever since
it's interesting to me when we have
these these big projects you know I
recently had Raja mocking me on from
Facebook the ambassador in Facebook a
personal advisor to Mark Zuckerberg is
the person that brought Sheryl Sandberg
in and he said the same thing his his
story tallies up with yours that very
soon after he was involved in a project
which would end up changing
the face of the Internet he was able to
see a particular trajectory that this
project was moving on which concerned
him and he highlighted it very early and
again with that the people who he
highlighted it to the powers that be
said don't think it's a problem
apparently they his analogy was that
they treated him like a PR a PR concern
to be dealt with
and replied he sent I don't know whether
you did this but I think he actually
created quite an extensive press release
slash proposal which for him was a
thesis laying out where the issues lay
it was his conceptualization of exactly
what was going on and apparently the
reply that he got from remarking from
Cheryl was similar to how a bad you
would do you would deal with something
in a press release bad press release
which I thought was really interesting
interesting yeah yeah well I I was nice
I didn't like go to the make a public
spectacle of the thing in in 2000 I mean
I think I considered it I didn't
actually go public with any criticisms
until 2004 and that really pissed
Jimmy Wales off one of the things he
responded to that on in its its on an
out defunct group blog called corrosion
k u r 5h i n org anyway and he basically
I said yeah I was thinking of you know
hiring you back and getting you back
involved and but not now and I said well
I wouldn't have come back if you had
asked because that the problems were not
getting better and some of the things
that I saw which is a tendency to ignore
the neutrality policy have gotten worse
I mean that's that's been a problem
since I would say
a couple of years after I left it
started when when one could begin to see
an ideological tilt to at least some of
the articles not always but that that
goes back to like maybe 2004 or 2005
then it started getting really
pronounced like 2010 lately though like
in the last three or four years
basically in the same time that
mainstream media has decided to abandon
all pretense of objectivity Wikipedia
has more or less followed suit as far as
I can tell that's so that's so upsetting
for me to hear so first off is I did a
little bit background reading into this
particular situation how'd it good chat
with visi is the guy who put me in you
in church and I'm as a part of that I've
definitely seen recently I was watching
Stephen Crowder and he was he said
something this is only the other day
about the fact his Wikipedia page has
been locked down
apparently it's had malicious edits made
to it and is now locked down and this is
I'm not even kidding me Larry this was a
week ago
and I heard this for the first time and
I am you know spend a fair bit time on
the Internet and I would swim in these
sort of circles hadn't heard anything
and you're talking about something which
is nearly two decades deep now with
regards to this particular pathology
that's going on so I'm thinking about
this and then it's gotten worse though
as what I'm saying oh yeah you saw the
seeds of it right back in the day oh
yeah can you explain to us in your world
what would make the perfect wiki and how
does that how does that contrast with
what you saw and then how is that begun
to diverge further as times gone on well
I'll give you first what I think is
there would be the perfect wiki and then
I will I will give you the way I think
encyclopedias generally should go which
is not necessarily in the form of wikis
at all so let me tell you about a couple
of projects that I worked on
and the the very best version of a wiki
encyclopedia might combine both so I
actually started a competing wiki
project called citizendium as in the
citizens compendium um back in 2006 2007
and that was just when Wikipedia was
enjoying his steepest growth curve so it
never really took off but it had a
really great start
and so the distinctive features that it
had really weren't enough to really
distinguish it from Wikipedia but they
were important differences one was you
had to use your own real name so Anna
maybe anonymity was not was not
permitted except in special cases in
which case we allowed pseudonyms right
so if somebody wanted if somebody were a
political dissident they would have to
trust me at least and I would like mom
you know approve of an account and and
then they could just like um use a
pseudonym alright that I think just
takes care of a heck of a lot of the
problems it did in in that yours that I
was working on citizendium and the other
thing that that helps basically solve a
lot of the problems with Wikipedia is
making all of the people who contribute
to the project agree to a statement of
fundamental principles and now Wikipedia
itself has you know some bedrock
policies that that it has stated but the
the its commitment to neutrality in
particular is as really on the ropes so
I think that if people were made to
agree in advance with policies that you
know are specifically devoted to strict
notions of neutrality and and other
important policies it goes a long way
basically and then a third thing is we
had a essentially a constitutional
system of governance of project
governance it it's not mob rule there
are actual elections people people can
actually change the rules through a
legit illegitimate process they can
adopt new projects through legitimate
process and there that doesn't really
exist on Wikipedia as crazy as that
might sound
it just doesn't so and that's in large
part because they don't have one-person
one-vote the reason for that is that
well they allow anonymity so that's one
of the one of the problems there so the
other project that I want to tell you
about is one that I've been working on
since a late 2007 so I have been chief
information officer of a PDA and ever
pedia is the encyclopedia of everything
that's why it's called Evra pedia and
it's now built on the blockchain so it's
the first blockchain encyclopedia it is
a fork of Wikipedia and we have decided
to allow contributions from all
different sources from all about all
different topics so we're much more open
as two contributors and topics where I
was Ricca pedia tends to shut people
down quickly there tend to be much more
closed than they used to be anyway
so we are going back to some of the more
positive or early tendencies I guess of
Wikipedia in that regard but one thing
that Wikipedia never had was this idea
that you could have an article about
absolutely anything so I have an article
about my left thumb just to demonstrate
that it is possible to have an article
about anything and it changes the nature
of the project
so if ever pedia really takes off in a
big way and it very well could then the
the result might be the the mass
creation of not 5 million articles in an
English encyclopedia but five hundred or
five billion articles about everything
all proper names is when one of the
co-founders put it anything has a proper
name would have an article that would be
attached to it so so here's the here's
another thing that that is not part of
that system yet but which I think any
system of collaborative encyclopedic
encyclopedia writing has to have and
that is a democratic dispute resolution
system usually what happens and this is
why Wikipedia one of the reasons why
Wikipedia is so messed up is that there
is no formalized way of arriving at a
decision about disputed questions so you
go there you've you've got a question
about you know what what should the the
definition of racism be you know
extremely hot topic it should be
possible for people to you know come up
with a bunch of different options and
maybe have a round-robin competition or
something like that and
actually get a legitimate choice that's
not what they do they pretend that it is
possible to have a consensus about about
these things and that the consensus is
determined basically by the people in
power on the topic you know River
whoever has the most seniority or seems
to have the most allies or whatever
those are the people who basically
declare the consensus so it's not a
consensus it's just putting a cynical
description on what is not it consensus
all so no there it means the
decision-making process needs to be
reduced to very specific editorial
decisions to be made and then taking
legitimate legitimate votes based on
that so I've never submitted an article
to Wikipedia or I've never tried to make
an amendment to Wikipedia I think
probably maybe back in the day when I
was a teenager out of what search to see
if I was on Wikipedia for any reason but
other than that and other than using it
for definitions like probably most
people haven't can you just briefly
explain what the process is that say I
want to I go on and I search for racism
and I think oh I have some some
information which relates to this that I
think is missing how do I go about
trying to edit the article well it's in
one way it's as simple as it could
possibly be you don't even need to make
an account except for protected accounts
like the one that you were mentioning
before they just go to the page you
press the Edit this page link up comes
an edit box you type in what you want
and you hit save and your your edit will
be saved immediately and it used to work
pretty much that way okay back back in
the day and then gradually things became
more and more locked down I think it
really started happening maybe in like
2008
2010 and now it's just it's really
difficult to to for anybody who is not
in an inner circle as it were
to edit any important article at all
really I mean you can propose edits and
maybe if they're I don't know but yeah
it's hard it's interesting cuz I would
get bad I'll tell you something if you
were to go in and edit the definition of
racism in the article about racism I'll
bet you'd be bad just for trying really
yeah I'm pretty sure I am pretty damn
sure I'd love for somebody to prove me
wrong someone try there's gonna be
thousands of people listening right now
so I'm gonna go and try and edit an
article about about something can us and
send us a screen show you know don't do
with that article do about how to make
jelly odds you know something something
that's kind of nondescript so no no it
has to be something to be a real test it
has to be something that is
controversial
just don't do racism jeez no I want
something else so I can immediately see
and the listeners will be able to think
as well if you allow people to make
instant edits the opportunity for trolls
there is is prevalent oh it's obvious
right that you can just have someone go
on and change every word of the Tipu and
then it just destroys the article that's
easy to fix
okay there's a there's a revert button
is there of some kind yes on the back
end yep exactly there's that it's all
made been made automatic because it's
much easier for for you to revert
somebody's illicit change then for the
person to make it in the first place
yep great point there's a lot more work
so there's an asymmetry in terms of work
that someone who wants to destroy
something has to do you actually quite
rare isn't it
entropy doesn't usually work that way
but yeah good point
so okay we have we have that we have we
have this particular system but you've
mentioned about the fact that you have
this this particular ideological leaning
with regards to Wikipedia and why what
it is and isn't allow
and also the fact that you have this
less than fair distribution of power
with regards to the editing of articles
however how's that manifesting on the
actual platform so if I go on I try to
edit something just doesn't get allowed
you doesn't save straightaway so there's
certain protected articles is that the
way it works certain protected articles
unless you actually have enough you have
made enough edits in the system you're
not allowed to touch them at all but you
know it doesn't take that long to get to
the point where you actually are
licensed in the system to to edit even
the protected articles but yeah I mean I
don't actually think that that in itself
is is such a terrible problem because I
mean it
there are popular articles need to be
locked down for the simple reason that
it's it ends up being just a chore to to
clean up after the the vandals right
things right exactly that's exactly what
happens
so there's I'm not complaining about
that that the complaint that I would
have is is the abuse of such a policy
they locking down an article so that
that people that you who are outsiders
they have legitimate contributions to
make to the article but you disagree
with them those people are excluded it
that's what that's a problem
yeah that must be such a effortful
process on the back end on the on the
end of Wikipedia to constantly be
looking what what article falls within
the purview of our protected racket is
this edit in line with our particular
thinking does it blah blah like that's
that's a serious unless I suppose unless
it's just a it doesn't get through this
is a very very hard wall well it's not
like there are some centralized rules
and
and and worldview that is that is
enforced by everyone I mean to a certain
extent that's okay kind of true but not
really it but it doesn't matter right
because because there's all kinds of
people who have made their own little
fiefdom
on their set of the set of articles that
they sit on and there's just a game that
you have to play in order to get
anything done on Wikipedia and that game
appeals to only a very few people so if
I may let me let me explain what's going
on now with me because it's it's it
develops you're basically asking what is
my notion of the the perfect wiki or the
perfect encyclopedia system so here it
is so I I said that I have been the
chief information officer of ever a PD
well actually as we speak now I am no
longer so I I resigned in in September
in order to start the knowledge
standards foundation and we are going to
be developing something that I call the
in cyclist sphere now the in cyclists
fear will be hopefully have as a partner
ever pedia but also Wikipedia and
ballotpedia and Britannica and the
Stanford encyclopedia of philosophy
and the rest of them not necessarily
partners in the sense that will have and
a written agreement with them but what
we're gonna do is we're going to take
metadata about all of their articles and
make it freely available as part of a
public Commons everyone can use and if
their articles are free as in the case
of Wikipedia every pedia and ballotpedia
and actually quite a few others if it is
free then you'll be able to see the
articles themselves they will also be
shared
made available as part of a public
Commons so what do I mean by public
comments actually means something like
the blogosphere so you can you know
right if you start up a blog if you
don't tell it not to then WordPress for
example will publish your posts using a
standard called RSS Really Simple
Syndication right so it makes what's
called a feed and that feed can be
slurped up by by blog readers and so you
can go and look at feedly for example
and feedly will allow you to subscribe
to different news sources and blogs
right and then your blog gets collated
in with other things that you might want
to read and so forth well we need to
build that kind of system for
encyclopedias that's what needs to exist
see if you want to work on an
encyclopedia now you have to work in and
you want to work on the the biggest most
influential encyclopedia in the world
well that's Wikipedia and you have to
work with that weird crew with their
strange policies with you know and and
put up with their ideological editing
and so forth you have to work on one
article per topic they don't allow
multiple articles on a competing
articles or anything like that of course
right well I submit that there are
probably millions of people who if given
the chance would be writing encyclopedia
articles about what they know if they
could be submitted into a general
Commons in the same way that people
submit blog posts into the general
Commons of the blogosphere so what we
need to do is create an n cyclists fear
that enables the millions of people who
would like to write encyclopedia
articles but who don't want to put up
the BS of Wikipedia so that's the idea
that's what we're building how do you
get around so you would presumably have
multiple articles on the same topic
multiple encyclopedia entries on the
same topic for me
I may be judging what I consider to be
an encyclopedia incorrectly but
presumably this should eventually only
be one for most things is that increase
that the wrong way to look at an
encyclopedia I think that's the wrong
way to look at it interests um yeah so
here's the problem
I I personally am an Objectivist about
truth I believe that there is such a
thing as a mind independent reality and
we can get closer or farther away from
from correct description of it alright
so there's a mind independent reality
and it constrains what we can know about
it but the problem is that there is no
generally accepted methods and certainly
no political entities that everyone can
agree with for determining what that
truth is right and and the best way to
arrive at the truth is to get all the
views on the table to be as as open as
possible to proposals and then allow
people to to rate those different
articles and then we can if we have a
proper user account system set up right
then if I've confirmed that I am in fact
Larry Sanger then I could say things
like well I'm an American I'm male I'm
you know over 50 I have a PhD I have
degrees in philosophy
I'm a member of this organization I have
I went to these colleges and so forth
right and then based on those categories
or political party religion whatever
based on such categories you can say
okay show me the top-rated article
according to all of the you know white
male Republicans or about black female
Democrats or you know on in on certain
topics those categories probably won't
matter on other topics don't matter a
lot and it would be really really
interesting I think to compare the
top-rated article about jihad
according to let's say American college
professors versus Imams living in the
Middle East I'll bet they would be
different and it would be really
interesting to compare those articles
right what would what would the
top-rated article according to those
categories of people be and so not only
would it enable us to articulate
different points of view it would
actually incentivize by creating a
worldwide but completely decentralized
leaderless centerless contest to write
the best article about every topic from
every point of view so you wouldn't be
you wouldn't just get an article that is
approved by American college professors
or whatever it would be the best one
according to them and there would be
this constant competition to write a
better one so yeah there's all kinds of
things to be said about that but I'll
just leave it at that and let you ask
questions
I think it's cool it it kind of sounds a
little bit like reddit I guess well you
kind of up vote you up for particular
articles and the ones that are the most
although I guess you wouldn't have the
time degrading element of that how are
the difference there's a difference
reddit is doesn't constrain the the type
of thing that is submitted to a
subreddit
right this is just encyclopedia articles
understood I agree
how how useful do you think that this
would be or are there any concerns about
how useful this would be for a typical
layperson I want to find out about
Christopher Columbus right I don't to
find out about the I might do but
broadly I probably want the most
aggregated understanding of what
Christopher Columbus did now there may
be some one way way out there who
believes Christopher Columbus went back
in time from the 22nd century and etc
etc do you understand what I mean that
you have this potential for
disinformation to lagana
conspiracy theories and alternative
points of view whilst valid is that is a
an encyclopedia the place for those well
let's put it this way some things that
were once considered encyclopedia
theories are now regarded as true any in
cyclic on Spira sees sorry i think i've
misstated that and so any conspiracy
theories of the past rather that they
they're now regarded as that have been
discovered or are no longer conspiracy
theories they're just true right but at
one point there were conspiracy theories
yeah right okay so it that the point is
that that yes there is a way to to
approximate the mainstream view on any
subject right you just have to adjust
the groups of people you know the groups
of accounts that you're going to follow
for purposes of determining what the
ranking of articles is
you see what I'm saying so yeah I mean
it's I don't think that's necessarily
gonna be easy but I think it's like it's
a great idea and I think it's one that
we ought to be trying out I think it
sounds like a fascinating challenge and
I think depending on how sophisticated
the data is which you can crunch on the
back end it would be absolutely
fascinating to start to identify the
differences between you know we're
talking here broadly about quite
nebulous differences between this is how
someone may write something ideologies
difficult enough to define as it is
right it's kind of very wishy-washy but
if you were able to really draw out in
hard data where the exact differences
lie between one interpretation or
perhaps one platform's interpretation of
a particular issue I think that would be
that would be absolutely fascinating
right all right no I agree really
looking forward to it is it is it
technically a challenge for whoever
whoever the unfortunate person is that's
got codes try and code this thing well
it's not one thing to code it except
insofar as we're talking about the
standards right because you know there's
an in when you're talking about the
blogosphere again to return to the
analogy I like to draw it's there is no
one set of software for the blog sphere
there's just the standards there's just
the specification RSS and atom and
that's it so that actually is not going
to be easy just making sure we have the
right standards expressed so I I've
actually started a wordpress blog
actually and you might not even be able
to tell that it's a blog by the time
we're done with it we're adapting it so
much but yeah it's gonna be a big old
group discussion but a serious long-form
discussion about what the standards
should
look like and I'm I've already started
reaching out to a lot of people and
we're gonna try to get as many relevant
experts involved and make sure that that
we've got everything nailed down as much
as possible but also in a way that the
that isn't that isn't interfered with by
big-money interests and and and the
power brokers of the world just don't
want them involved at all so we're not
going to accept any corporate money
we're not going to accept any money from
governments any any large contributions
we accept from individuals or or may be
found in Family Foundation's or whatever
we're gonna actually check them out
gonna make sure that they're not another
epstein you know that kind of thing we
want the money to be clean and we want
to make sure that if there is no quid
quo pro involved so because knowledge is
power right and and the if we actually
succeed in developing the the project
that that I'm talking about it could be
extremely powerful actually and I think
there might be people after after it to
exert influence so that there's a
special favors done to certain people
and that's that isn't gonna happen I
want it to be as neutral of and
Democratic standard as as the classic
standards of you know defining the
Internet have been understood yeah so
when you're talking about the knowledge
standards foundation itself the actual
platforms I'm going to guess that you're
dealing with Wikipedia and stuff like
that
in terms of repurposing their content
and pulling them across that they all
within a format which is usable at the
moment for you to rip that metadata
route not really know do you need to get
them on board with what you're going to
do no I am not necessarily understood I
mean it would help yeah we could
probably use their help but I don't
think it will be necessary in the case
of MediaWiki that's the name of the
software that that Wikipedia uses yeah
we can we can write basically a scraper
for MediaWiki sites that extracts the
the right metadata thing is people do
use media wiki in different ways so that
that would itself need to be adapted I'm
pretty sure we're gonna have to to adapt
our scrapers for basically all the
different sites and I'm not just talking
about a Meta Search Engine though to be
very clear what I want to exist is like
plugins for for WordPress or from a
browser browser plugins that you could
use when you're working on a medium
article for example you press a button
it imports the data on the page into a
form and then you fill out other fields
to make sure and make sure that
everything is is correct and then it
republish is it on a feed in a feed and
then that feed could may be another
thing that it could do is ping one of
the at one of the feed aggregators right
and that will pull in different
encyclopedia feeds from different
encyclopedias but also and this is the
point individuals if you just want to
put up an encyclopedia article about
your hobby and you like okay I don't
know a lot about a lot but I can write
you know a dozen articles about about
table tennis cards yes yeah yeah
Trainspotting yeah whatever
then then that's fine you'll be able to
do that
and they will be collated in ranked
against all the others I think I just
can't get over how big of a technical
undertaking this is like it sounds it
just sounds like because obviously from
your side philosophically it is very
interesting another thing that I've got
in my head at the moment is the is how
similarly this matches up with what's
happening with blockchain technology at
the moment with with decentralization of
currencies and stuff like that this is
why I joined every pedia right and every
pedia is is still committed to to using
this sort of system but when I when I
joined every pedia I said okay so this
is the project I really want to work on
so they said okay well you develop the
ideas and and you know you can give
speeches about it and that's what I did
but but also early on I said eventually
somebody is going to have to actually
define the standards the common
standards that are used if four people
are going to be submitting articles to
the ever pedia network then then they
would have to have common standards for
doing that and I eventually came to the
conclusion that if it's really gonna be
open and not controlled by every pedia
Inc then it actually has to be something
that is built not on the blockchain
but builds on on the World Wide Web
basically so just it'll be basically a
text feed right and but of course you
know every PTO will in fact be able to
tokenize that work perhaps you'll have
to do something special in order to get
an article submitted to Wikipedia maybe
you'd have to have an ever pedia account
in order to earn IQ tokens for doing
that right but you're you're not at all
wrong that that the whole idea of
decentralizing content development is is
something that people are really excited
about
a blockchain for enabling so it's
interesting isn't it that this
particular pathways acting across
multiple different domains so to speak
within tech this this push towards
decentralization yeah it's just a it's a
it's a movement basically to to take
power back take it out of the hands of
Mark Zuckerberg and and his ilk right
yeah it's a I think it's a huge problem
that they have decided to ignore our
privacy rights and even though our
content is what they have built their
you know multi-billion dollar
corporations
on they insist on censoring us it's the
arrogance is mind-boggling to me and
that wouldn't fly if you were talking
about blogs would it yes yes there's no
central blogging Authority why the hell
does there have to be a central tweeting
authority or a central you know social
update Facebook update kind of authority
it doesn't have to be it's it's
increasingly now I'm hearing this
discussion about is it pipeline versus
platform or pipeline versus publishing
which is the analogy which is being used
that there are either simply the
delivery vehicle for whatever people put
on there or there a publishing platform
which curates the content which goes out
and apparently there's some very
different rulings legislatively in terms
of copyright in terms of a whole host of
other things which every platform right
now YouTube Twitter there's again to go
back to steven crowder he unloaded a
load of stuff in this one one video i
watch the other week he was talking
about it which showed his analytics on
his youtube channel
and apparently YouTube has made a
essentially a forthright declaration of
the fact that there will be restricting
political speech in the build-up to the
American election and I was thinking
like this it's crazy it's absolutely
insane
yeah and but that's because maybe for me
I don't see the I hope that these
particular organizations are these big
transparent enablers of information
freedom right that's what I think but
that's what we all thought
absolutely and as these organizations
grow they need tax breaks they need
favours they potentially get into some
legislative problems they need to favor
off someone someone needs a favor off
them they grow a bit more they grow a
bit more they get someone on the board
and you can see how these sort of this
the beautiful princess of purity dressed
in all white kind of gets a bit more
mucky as time goes on and the dress gets
a bit dirty and torn and then she's you
know grown an extra arm and kind of
become this gargoyle after a while and
it is it's bizarre and it's you know
again the same that Roger McNamee said
the same thing Tristan Harris is talking
about the Center for Humane Technology
and a lot of the people that I'm very
interested in at the moment yourself II
now added to that list Larry it's
interesting that this movement is toward
decentralization towards more
transparency and I wonder if we'll see
some of the large organizations either
dig their heels in aggressively trying
claw at particular projects or what some
of the reactions will be because there's
no chance that they're going to go down
without a fight okay I have a data point
on that it's interesting so last spring
I had this idea that we really need to
decentralize social media and I gave a
speech at South by Southwest in Austin
Texas and I I asked just out into the
public space
I asked Jack Dorsey that CEO of Twitter
or three questions so question number
one was will you agree jack to let us
republish our tweets into a common data
format that could be used on other
platforms like Facebook or brand-new of
platforms and will you also enables to
import posts into our Twitter feeds on
twitter.com or the Twitter app from
other sources so say my friend isn't
using Twitter but is posting a lot on
minds and I want to see all of all of
the social media activity in one place
will you enable us to import those posts
and then a third I said well you just
generally give us a hell of a lot more
control over the algorithm that are the
algorithms that that shape our our feeds
and somebody you know wrote down the
questions and and tweeted them at Jack
and Jack responded he said yes so I
actually clarified I said okay here's
question one do you agree and said yes
here's entak uestion - do you agree with
that yes question three do you agree
that yes so he he was on the record on
Twitter saying yes to the
decentralization of Twitter it hasn't
happened yet though it hasn't happened
yet and I'll tell you more I'll tell you
something else I had a half hour long
discussion I so out of the blue I got a
a message from Jack a direct message and
proposing that we chat so I had a half
an hour long discussion with him on the
phone and he read to me what sounded
like a plan that somebody had written
that
went into details about the sorts of
things that I had asked questions about
like this is I mean it sounded great
like it was a real plan of course they
haven't talked about this plan stuff
you've got Jack Dorsey the CEO of
Twitter on the phone for half an hour to
speak about something you brought up
South by Southwest to do with
decentralizing Twitter yep that is
that's big that's really big you would
think it's big but nobody ever wrote any
any news stories about it ever
I think it's pretty big I thought it was
pretty big too so
nothing nothing happened and and that
kind of pissed me off so I didn't really
pull any punches sorry
oh well that the the conversation I
think it was in March or I think was
March um yeah cause I mean in the in the
tech world things move fast but in a big
company like Twitter I guess there's
probably a like things move pretty slow
right it could still happen it could
still happen for sure okay but there's
another thing okay I decided to do a
social media strike in in July July 4th
in July 5th I invited people to sign a
declaration of digital independence yeah
that's cool yeah you should read it and
sign it it's still up it's on my blog
Larry Sanger dot or just search for
declaration of digital independence and
I told people strike on July 4th and 5th
and a bunch of people did I don't know a
thousands and thousands of people did
and they were declaring that they were
on strike and so forth I got there were
dozens of articles written about it - I
was on CNN I was on Fox talking to know
what's his name
anyway yeah and and so it was as far as
getting the idea out there goes that was
a success not that many people actually
run on strike but it was a focus superb
for a few and here's the interesting
thing after that like beginning toward
the end of July and since then Facebook
has gone down from an Alexa rank of
three to five Twitter has declined from
11 to 30 today their Alexa rank is
thirty today used to be eleven right
I've written an article about this on my
on my blog there's various others that
there are big decliners like Instagram
is another one has gone down like 25 or
30 places knows this Alexa ranks
publicly available yeah yeah it's just
like I've never heard of it it's so -
the ranking of how many people are
asking Alexa to do a particular thing is
that correct
nope oh it's it's it's the this the the
ranked ranking of websites it's not
Alexa it's also a an Amazon product but
actually predates the the Alexa device
so what is it's it's a web traffic
service basically understood yeah yeah
yeah I think it's so this is a much more
certain people no bigger than a smart
speaker to not to to access Instagram
this is general truck yes going down
this is general traffic going down Oh
wikipedia has gone from a ranking of it
is used to be the fifth most popular
website now it is the ninth just in the
last six to eight weeks of the be
notable ascensions yeah there have been
a few
it's interesting Bing has gone up the
search engine Microsoft Office has gone
up eBay a little bit Stack Overflow has
gone up a lot on Stack Exchange has gone
up Apple for some for whatever reason
released new iPhone that's why when you
release it you probably right you're
probably right medium and then then all
kinds of mainstream traffic sources
sorry traffic sources main scene news
sources have gone up
I think they've absorbed traffic from
declining social media sites and this is
my theory yes my theory BBC ESPN New
York Times Washington Post Fox News
Breitbart Wall Street Journal have all
gone up significantly in the last three
months isn't that interesting
yeah yeah oh another one that that has
gone down a lot is Pinterest Pinterest
so it's I don't call people interesting
Quorra how the mighty have fallen
Quorra used to be at rank 82 and it's
now down to I know 200 and lower let's
see what the latest is here just a
second
262 Wow did he say 180 points did the
big hoo-ha between them and Jordan
Peterson about a month ago I'm not sure
I did okay so Jordan Peterson's book 12
rules for life was originally based on a
Korra post someone asked him what are
the best piece of advice that you would
give someone for life and he wrote he
wrote 40 Maxim's or aphorisms whatever
you want to call them
he wrote a list how did that yeah okay
risk I've got the poster of all 40
outside in my hallway next to my
bathroom
I know it's he wrote these 40 and it's
like one of the most engaged Quora posts
of all time it's legendary and it got
taken down because it because it
trevean community standards then he
appealed it very very very publicly
screenshotting what the process is he's
going through with kora and they came
back to him and said we're very sorry
were not going to reinstate your post
because we've reviewed it manually and
it does indeed contravene our community
standards so it's down and you are never
getting it back and he put he put this
post up online
his followers reacted appropriately and
then he got a DM from someone who worked
at the standards department at Quora
just a just a guy some guy and he was
like give me give me a couple of days
like just hold on give me a couple of
days and again he's publishing this
public publishing this exchange with
this particular this this gentleman and
he reinstates it but it not out not
until they've been through this big
process that just every single time that
this happens every time the Steven
Crowder's article gets locked down or
the Douglas Murray write released a
podcast with him two day you know who he
is he does never bluetick on Twitter
I've got a blue tick on Twitter and over
the TV I went on a TV program seven
years ago and I've got a blue T it's
[ __ ] I didn't have a blue tick until
until um a until after I talked to
generate it you created Wikipedia that's
it
shoot away like you just got one favor
to ask you may well like how doesn't
Douglas Murray have a blue tick and it's
right did you listen to Jack Dorsey when
he went on Joe Rogan twice both times I
did well I I listened to one of them for
three hours yes it was that the one
where he had himself and Tim what's his
name oh yes yes I get the one before
that was pointless so just as well but
yet that one with temple and Tim's right
like it always appears to be to be kind
of viciously left-leaning it always
appears to be the people that hold a
slightly more conservative viewpoint or
don't
perhaps a deer to the social justice
mentality as much that the ones that are
suffering so yeah every time that this
happens it just makes people lose faith
in tech and do you know the one the one
group that Roger McNamee of the whole
thing this big conversation and there's
this footnote at the end and as I so
tell me like it we need to use
technology I want to get an uber I want
to direct myself from where I am to the
hotel that I'm staying in tomorrow night
what what's the best of the bad bunch
and Rogers Dimond in the roof was Apple
so he said the Apple is genuinely
committed to user privacy he said that
it it works incredibly hard to do a
number of things that are losing the
money so he said Apple Maps loses tons
of money so once you've finished your
journey it splits it up into ten pieces
and then scatters them across the god
knows where it deletes them so they
can't be found people can't track you
all this sort of stuff but across the
board it would appear you know the olds
establishments of the internet Wikipedia
Twitter YouTube Google [ __ ] kora like
yeah they're not they're no longer the
same sort of trusted institutions and I
guess that's exactly where things like
the knowledge standards foundation and
other organizations there is a gap in
the market for someone to come in and
first off create a standard and then
secondly be about voice of reason
yeah now it's it's actually the way I
would put it is there are things that
are considered in markets that didn't
used to be considered markets and should
no longer be do we talk about the blog
market right no do we talk about the
email market no they're just
communication media and and of course
you can make blogging and email products
there's nothing wrong with that and in
the same way you'll be able to to make a
you know Encyclopedia apps and things
like that there'll be nothing wrong with
that either but I I had to comment on
what you were saying about about Apple
so I mean I am not that at
I mean I agree that Apple talks a good
game I and and have taken some public
stands that indicate that they are more
serious about about privacy but there's
a lot of things that they do that are
not are not that great for privacy and
and insecurity
so I actually recently bought i
pre-ordered and will soon have delivered
the first mass-produced Linux phone so
it's made by a company called purism and
it's called the Libre five it's the
first Linux phone how cool is that it's
it's a third phone ecosystem it's a
third smartphone ecosystem you'll be
able to actually access the the command
line for your phone be able to plug it
in and show show that the desktop you
know run it like a computer and you know
anybody will be able to make apps and
you know have to get special permission
from Apple to to run the apps and so I'm
excited about that I think that's really
how it ought to be I don't know if it'll
ever get as big as you know Apple and
Android but well you can always hope
convenience convenience is so high
they're right for users yeah it needs to
be the the kiddies sandpit version of of
whatever it is that we're talking about
it's the same reason that I'm not
running Linux on my on my laptop I'm
using I'm using a MacBook because Linux
is easier than telling you I wouldn't
have said that when I first had first
installed Linux like back in 2002 or
whatever it was I understood Hat Linux
and this is it was definitely for geeks
only then now yeah now it's totally
different game basically it's easier to
install
all Linux first of all than it is to
install Windows at least some versions
of Linux like like Ubuntu and a few
others but the actual day to day use if
you if you wanted grandma to have a
daily use machine and she didn't know
about computers wasn't used to anything
you'd give her Linux and it would it
would be better she's never gonna have
to go to the command-line anymore
Linux rocks no I'm telling you could you
imagine if you gave you grandma Linux
for a couple of months and you came back
and she was just like she had a vertical
a portrait external monitor and she's
doing the hardcore coding Larry it's
been awesome can you tell we spoke about
your blog in the knowledge of Science
Foundation why can people go they want
to learn a little bit more why should
they head well I hope they would do a
couple of different things you can look
at at my blog you're just interested in
my thoughts about life the universe and
everything actually mostly mostly tech
and education because I homeschool my
boys but if you want to just like keep
up with me then please subscribe follow
me on Twitter or at sale Sanger and then
also on twitter is KS underscore found
as in knowledge standards foundation if
you could follow that I just put out a
call for people to like to follow that
and for some reason it went viral and I
went from 60 followers to like I've
almost got a hundred and fifty now all
right sir 1500 so in just a couple of
days look like so yeah yeah that's your
mate jack that's your mate Jack right
now he's a good guy I had a good chat
with you a couple of months ago we'll
keep up we'll keep up we'll let the
algorithm work on for another couple of
months I any any sort of image that I
here is his lockdown is sensitive
content I swear I just said I just
posted something it was just just saying
thank you for putting us up over a
thousand that's what it said that's all
it said it was marked as sensitive
content some x-rated sharing that you've
obviously got going on there Larry
Africa I've had a few acts guest lived
in that as well but yes everything that
we've spoken about knowledge Sanders
foundation your blog Larry and your
Twitter will be linked in the show notes
below I'm excited I'm looking forward to
seeing what happens over the next few
the next few months it'll be it'll be
exciting to see if you guys managed to
change the the space of the Encyclopedia
in cyclists fear just like the
blogosphere in cyclists fear I love it
Larry thank you so much for your time
[Music]